Here you can see a simple app that
creates a table showing someone's
favorite things.
Remember that at the very least,
this table needs two things
from its data source.
The number of rows, and
the cell for each row.
If we focus on the ViewController.swf
file for a second, here we can see
the favorite things model,
which is just an array of strings.
So how does the UITableView
know how many rows it has?
A table view finds out how many rows
it has by asking its data source.
More specifically, by invoking
the data source protocol method,
number of rows in section.
Check out the get branch
in the instructor notes.
And inspect the project in
ViewController.swf files.
Play around with the methods
to see what they do,
and then indicate your choice below.
Given that the table will invoke
this method on the view controller,
which implementation seems right?